في اواخر ستينات واوائل سبعينات القرن
العشرين انطلق برنامج ابولو نحو القمر
محملا باثني عشر رائد فضاء جميعهم من
الرجال السؤال هنا لماذا فقط من الرجال
قبل ان نتحدث عن الاجابه الخبر اليوم ان
امريكا تستعد لارسال اول امراه الى سطح
القمر وبعد عقود من وصول الرجل ستصل
المراه الى جارنا القمر على كل حال وفقا
لبيانات الامم المتحده فان النساء يشكلنا
احد 10% من رواد الفضاء ونحو 20% من القوى
العامله في قطاع الفضاء ونحو 30% من
الباحثين في المجال وبالرغم من الجهود
المبذوله لزياده عدد النساء في الفضاء الى
ان ارقام 2021 اظهرت انه من اصل
50066 شخصا ذهبوا الى الفضاء اعتبارا من
مارس 20 20 كانت 65 امراه منهم فقط فلماذا
هذه التفرقه الفضائيه الكبيره بين الرجال
والنساء اذن
[موسيقى]
امريكا تستعد لارسال الاول امراه الى
القمر اهميه هذا الحدث الذي طال انتظاره
لماذا طال انتظاره حتى اليوم
اولا الاداره الامريكيه او اداره ناسا
غيرت رايها تماما في اختيار الجنس يعني
سواء ذكر او انثى فعلا في الاول كان يقول
المراه اكثر تاثرا بالاشعاع النهارده
برنامج ارتميس اللي هو هيطلع همم للقمر
ويعمل مستعمره قمريه همم لا بالعكس اختار
18 همم رائد فضاء من ضمنهم تسعه نساء في
النصف اخذ 50% وبعدين حتى كلمه ارتي بس دي
عباره عن يعني هي منسوبه الى جهه القمر
يعني ليله واحده ست برده او واحده سيده
يعني هي في الاساطير الاغريقيه بيقولوا
هذا الكلام يعني العالم غير همم
نهج وتماما وناس كده
طلع ان شاء الله في 24 هيطلع رائده فضاء
وواحد برده اخر من جنس او من سكان
الاصليين
اكون
المراه في الفضاء بحكم ان طبيعه النفس
البشريه للنساء اقوى في ادق التفاصيل مسح
ودراسه ما يجري بكامل تفاصيلها
المراه اكثر احتمالا من الرجل يعني احنا
لازم نعترف بهذا يعني وطبعا للمؤشرات
الجديده في اختيار رائدات الفضاء لا
النهارده اصبحوا يمثلوا 50% بالضبط من
الرجال وانا اعتقد بقى ان هم عن ال همم
رائده الفضاء على اسمها ولكن اعتقد ان هي
ان نقول يعني لانها لها خبره كبيره جدا
وبرده حتى صحتها جيده جدا وهمم مش كبير
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان فعلا ناس هتختار
هذه السيده لانها اوريدي همم يعني هتطلع
في معك في الدوليه او طلعت وهتقعد خمس
اشهر فهم عارفين ان هي شديده الباس ولاء
قدره كبيره على التحمل وانا اعتقد بنسبه
اكثر من 90% ان فعلا نيكون ونابو ااا من
هي اللي هتكون دكتور اكثر دقه واكثر قدره
على التحمل لكن هل بالفعل هي اكثر تاثرا
بالشعاعات العاليه للفضاء
يعني الموضوع ده تغير هو كان الاول فيه
بعض المؤشرات بتقول الكلام ده لكن ثبت خطا
في برنامج اللي هو طلع ارض نسوان طلع وفي
لسته
قالوا لا الكلام دوت
وبالتالي
نصف عدد رواد الفضاء المرشحين لبرنامج
ارتمس من النساء فالفكره اتغير تماما يعني
[موسيقى]